We had such a busy day today,
so we ordered food.
No, I did not cook anything from scratch today.
We've been doing baby stuff all day long.
Building cribs,
doing the whole thing.
So we ordered food.
Obviously we ordered Thai food.
So we got a few dishes.
These are still piping hot.
I think they forgot our rice bubs.
No. So we got.
What is this? Oh, okay.
We got some plain rice,
cause we got this little stir fry situation.
We got some chicken basil stir fry.
We got. Oh, this is what?
This is such a tiny portion. Holy crap.
I got mango sticky rice.
Wait, is there rice in there? Yeah,
This is tiny,
but I've been craving it all day long.
There's nothing better to me than mango and sticky rice.
Then lucky got drunken noodles.
Oh, my goodness,
this looks so good.
Can I have some of it? Yes, baby.
Then I got this glass noodle stir fry.
Lucky always orders food,
and it looks better to me than mine.
Mine does look the best,
I'll be honest.
So I usually get.
I usually eat what he's eating.
What else did we get?
Oh, we also got a mango limeade.
We usually get everything like medium spicy,
but lucky always needs extra spice.
Come on. He also eats everything with hot sauce.
Do we plate this or do we just.
No, let's just eat it out of the
Container looks still really hot.
We don't have to warm it up, right?
Yeah. Let me just try it.
Uh huh. It's good. Uh huh.
Try. Good. I'm gonna try yours.
Do you wanna turn on next level chef? Yes, I do.
We don't really watch shows lately.
Well, that's. No,
we've been watching Love Is Blind, Babe. Oh yeah,
we watch Love Is Blind.
We're waiting. Iconic.
We're waiting for the last.
It is iconic, honestly.
Uh huh. Uh huh.
It's good. Yeah.
So baby like it? Uh huh.
Alright, baby loves,
we're gonna go sit down and eat now.